my name is Mike this is old system
constantly obviously many don't listen
to a word daddy says listen man I'll be
very honest with them she was inspired
by you and was feel completely
inappropriate for me to tell me anything
I think what you're doing is incredible
I have a three-year-old daughter named
Isha that you know I aspire to have on
my lap and things like this and have
these kind of conversations and race for
it not even on the word of the Box way
but in a way that I think will become
the future you know I've always lived in
the future right and that's where a lot
of my success comes from I think that
Mandy I think that you may not
understand sir your question Mandy I
think you may not understand what I'm
about to say but luckily this is a video
when one day you'll watch it you were
very very very lucky to have a daddy
like this and I think that he really
cares this being thoughtful about how to
create a better life for you and I think
you should kiss him on the cheek
hi I'm Andy by the way please email me
at Gary yet you know mediacom while
you're watching this I know that it's 11
years from now but I delete that account
just so you know me and I cannot wait to
get your email